السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اه
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستهديه ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له ومن يضلل فلن تجد له
وليا مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده
لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين
اما بعد معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان
اصدق الكلام كلام الله عز وجل وخير الهدي
هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وان شر
الامور
محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه وان كل بدعه
ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار اسال الله
العظيم رب العرش العظيم بمنه وكرمه وعفوه
ان يجيرني واياكم منها انه ولي ذلك
والقادر عليه
يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق
منها
زوجها وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول
الله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ويقول
سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله وقولوا قولا سديدا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما ا
بعد لا شك اخي المسلم ان حياه المسلم كلها
لله سبحانه وتعالى من اول يومه
لاخره من ولده وماله
وعمله لاهله لثروته كلها لله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى قل ان
صلاتي ونسكي ومحياي ومماتي لله رب
العالمين لا شريك له وبذلك امرت وانا اول
المسلمين وهذا هو اصل العبوديه والغايه
التي خلقنا الله سبحانه وتعالى من
اجلها ولاجل بقاء
ذلك الدوام
التعبدي نهت
الشريعه عن التشدد في العباده وبينت ان
خيرها ما دام عليها صاحبها او ما داوم
عليها صاحبها وان قلت في الحديث ان رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال عندما سئل عن
احب
الاعمال الى الله قال ادومه وان
قل جعل الله سبحانه وتعالى الاعمال
الصالحه متفاضلا وافضلها التي يستمر عليها
صاحبها ويداوم عليها
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى
عء الله سبحانه وتالى
‏the
life bel الله سبحانه
وران
سهران الله سبحانه
وتالى
life my
my my life
and الله سبحانه وتالى
‏all and
ise
wor اصل
العبوديه عده الله سبحه
وتالى عباده
الله سبحانه
وتالى رحمه الله سبحانه وتالى
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى ادها وان قل
[Silence]
‏we
الصح ذكر ذلك خرجنا تو للتو من موسم
الطاعات والصيام
والقيام شهر رمضان المبارك فسبحان الله
يستثقل العبد بعدها ان يواصل على نفس
السرعه والاجتهاد فيصاب بالفتور والتعب
وربما الاحباط ل ليترك
العباده ولذلك اقول ان البشرى النبويه
اليوم كانت منه صلى الله عليه وسلم ان احب
الاعمال الى الله ادوامه وان
قل وهذا ممكن ان يتمثل بركعات بسيطات
يسيرا في
الليل وقران يسير خير من ان تتعبد الله
ليله كامله متواصله مره واحده في السنه
[Silence]
ضان any
other ق
قران
113 15ك
[Silence]
ضان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏main
not
est هذه القاده مستنبطه مستنبطه من من
جمله النصوص من السنه النبويه ارشد ارشد
فيها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم على
المداومه على العمل واثباته ولو كان
قليلا وكره المغالاه في الاعمال بما يكون
ماله الانقطاع او التقصير في تكاليف
اخرى في الحديث ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان يحتج حصيرا بالليل
فيصلي عليه ويبسط بالنهار فيجلس فيجلس
عليه فجعل الناس يرجعون اليه الى
النبي فيصلون بصلاته حتى كثروا فاقبل فقال
صلى الله عليه وسلم خذوا من الاعمال ما
تطيقون خذوا من الاعمال ما تطيقون فان
الله لا يمل حتى تملو وان ان احب الاعمال
الى الله ما دام وان
قل نتحدث اليوم عن الاستمراريه في العب في
العباده لذلك نؤكد ان ثلاث ركعات توتر بها
في الليل طيله ايام السنه خير من ال000
ركعه تتعبد فيها في ليله واحده مره واحده
في السنه المساله ليست
بالكثير
المنقطع المساله ليست بالكثير المنقطع ان
بالقل
المستمر صلى الله عليه وسلم ان حديث صلى
الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
وسلم did not like
this because what can do we
can صلى الله عليه وسلم us
[Silence]
‏said able
ع سبحان الله سبحان
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله
[Silence]
الله وعن عائشه رضي الله عنها ان رسول
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم دخل وعندها امراه فقال من هذه
فقلت امراه لا تنام تصلي الليل قال عليكم
من العمل ما تقون
فوالله لا يمل الله حتى تملوا وكان احب
الدين اليه ما داوم عليه صاحبه او
صاحبه وعن انس قال دخل رسول صلى الله عليه
عليه وسلم وسلم المسجد فاذا بحبل من بين
ساريتين هذا قالوا هذه زينب تصلي الليل
فاذا كسلت او فترت امسكت به
فقال
حلوه ليصلي
احد فاذا كسل او فتر
قعد سنه
[Silence]
عائشه رض عن صلى الله عليه
وسلم مسجد
[Silence]
قليل مستمر خير من كثير
منقطع بارك الله لي ولكم بالقران العظيم
ونفعني بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم
اقول ما تسمعون وا الله لي ولكم فاستغفروه
انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه
للعالمين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اللهم
وعنهم يا رب
العالمين ان التثبيت ولان التثبيت
والايمان قلنا صل بالقليل المستمر للكثير
المنقطع لفت القران الكريم الى ذلك في
ايه يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى وقال الذين
كفروا لا ن عليه القران جمله واحده كذلك
لنثبت به فؤاد تناه ترتيلا كتب التفاسير
تقول ان بين اول نزول القران واخره يعني
نزولا وحيا الى بي نحو من 20
سنه تنزل القران على النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم على نحو 20 سنه فسبحانه وتعالى قادرا
ان ينزله جمله
واحده كان هو السبب المذكور في الايه
ولذلك كذلك لنثبت به فؤادك ورتلناه ترتيلا
التثبيت والايمان بالكثير
[Silence]
المستم
قرانى الله عليه وسلم
قرى
علر جريل عليه
السلام
قران صل الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى كذلك لنثبت به فؤادك
باي وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل
وسلم على سيدنا محمد في الاخرين وصل وسلم
على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم صل
سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت
خير الوارثين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين واعل رايه
رايتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم يا ربنا
ويا مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء يا ذا الجلال
والاكرام حي يا قيوم يا بديع السماوات
والارض ويا رحمان الدنيا والاخره ورحيمهما
اللهم يا من تسمع كلامنا وترى مكاننا
وتعلم سرنا
وعلانيتنا اللهم ابرم لنا وابرم لهذه
الامه امرا رشدا تعز فيه ليك وتذل فيه
عدوك وتهدي فيه ويعمل فيه بطاعتك اللهم
انا نتوجه اليك باحب الاسماء اليك ونسالك
ونرجوك وانت وانت ونحن نؤمن انك انت
السميع المجيب القريب لا يخفى عليك شيء لا
في الارض ولا في السماء شيء اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوال المسلمين اللهم اصلح
احوالنا واحوال المسلمين في كل مكان
في غزه والسودان اللهم صن واحفظ اخواننا
المسلمين في كل مكان اللهم ارفع عن
اخواننا ظلم المعتدين اللهم ادفع عن
اخواننا كيد الغاصبين اللهم انا نعوذ بك
في من سرورهم وندرا بك في نحورهم اللهم
اجعل تدميرهم تدميرا
عليهم اللهم انا نسالك باهلنا في غزه
والسودان خيرا اللهم اجعلهم في ضمانك
اللهم ادخلهم في امانك اللهم ابني ع عليهم
سور حمايتك اللهم حطهم برعايتك اللهم
احرسهم بحراسته اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع
اللهم ادفع عنهم ودافع اللهم اجعل هذا
المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد المسلمين
بخير وعافيه وسلام وامان واطمئنان اللهم
اعطنا سؤلنا اللهم اعطنا سؤلنا اللهم اغفر
لنا خطيئتنا وجهلنا واسرافنا في امرنا وما
انت اعلم به منا اللهم اغفر لنا خطانا
وعمدنا وهزلنا وجدنا وكل ذلك عندنا اللهم
اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا وما اعلنا
وما اسررنا انت انت المقدم وانت المؤخر
وانت على كل شيء قدير اللهم تقبل منا انك
انت السميع العليم وتب علينا انك انت
التواب الرحيم اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا
محمد اللهم احينا على سنته وامتنا على
ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته يا رب
العالمين اللهم اجز سيدنا محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم خير ما جزيت نبيا عن امته اللهم
اجز نبينا صلى الله عليه وسلم خير ما جزيت
نبيا عن امته اللهم لك العتبه حتى ترضى
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بك عباد الله انمر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون واخر
دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين واقيم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استقيم
استووا سد الخلل سووا الصف لاين
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والليل اذا ي
والنهار اذا تجلى وما خلق الذكر
والانثى
ان سعيكم
لشتى
فاما من اعطى واتقى وصدق
بالحسنى فسنيسره
لليسرى واما من بخل واستغنى وكذب
للعسرى وما يغني عنه
ماله اذا تردى
ان علينا
للهدى
وان لنا للاخره
والاولى
فانذرتكم
نارا
تلظى لا يصلى
الا
الاشقى الذي كذب
وتولى
وسيجنبها الاتقى الذي يؤتي ماله
يتزكى وما لاحد عنده من
نعمه
تجزى الا
ابتغاء وجه ربه الاعلى
لسوف
يرضى الله
اك سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك
وما قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من
الاولى ولسوف يعطيك ربك
فترضى الم يجدك
يتيما فاوى
ووجدك
ضالا فهدى ووجدك
عائلا
فاغنى
فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر
واما
السائل فلا تنهر
واما نعمه ربك فح
حدث الله
اك سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏time
‏first
[Silence]
‏m
good
jate comate
‏people
close
take
and people
‏se look was very easy but i know
for that is not simple tk to
aeve
all ‏l